[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and Broad on Thursday the 8th of
February I'm Kate Andrew The Spectators
economics editor and your host this week
coming up on the
show Westminster is no stranger to a
plot especially one to oust a prime
minister now it's rishy Su next turn why
now and will it succeed Katie balls has
the story alongside the woman who wrote
about plots months ago naen dory's Brits
are being signed off work with long-term
sickness at a higher rate than ever
before is co the only thing to blame how
can we get people back into the
workforce our data editor Michael
Simmons and Universal Credit architect
Ian Duncan Smith join me on the show
over in France can Eric sore reclaim
support from the populace right Freddy
gray has been speaking to him for the
magazine this week we'll show you a clip
from that interview
two years on Russia's war in Ukraine
shows no signs of stopping but is
Ukraine's tactic to send older soldiers
to the front line working spit Lana
morets and historian Anthony Beaver join
me on the show and finally are men any
good at being feminists Zoe striple has
taken a look back at the author Thomas
Hardy who wrote beautifully about women
but did his stories match his actions
she joins me on the show before we get
going if you enjoy spectator TV do
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon to
make sure you never miss an
episode first up should Rishi cak be
worried about the plot to oust him from
number 10 writing the cover piece this
week Katie ball says the plotters are
focused on the next 100 days as a
general election gets closer someone
else who has written about the plot is
nine dor former minister in Tor MP
initially she was ridiculed for her
thesis and she's got some thoughts on
that now as her and Katie join me on the
show Katie in this week's magazine you
write about the plot to OU prime
minister Rishi sunk what is going on so
we often hear about plotting in
Westminster um particularly in recent
years moves against uh Tory Prime
Ministers and I think there's a
difference between Tory MPS telling you
how miserable they are how they're
thinking about writing a letter and what
is currently happening um because we've
had over the past couple of weeks a few
things where it's uh whether it's you
know a mysteriously funded poll in the
telegraph whether it's um Talk of former
government advisers working um to try to
ask RI sunak and I think although it's a
pretty loose group what has become
apparent is there is a cabal effectively
of disgruntled Tories who would like to
move against Rishi sunak before the next
election and I think a few months ago
the sense was oh that that contest and
that fight is for after the election and
the question is can this quite small
group and we know you know uh some some
are Anonymous donors some of former
government AIDS we know a few names to
do of it in the sense David Frost was
linked to this poll but I think as since
tried to distance himself a bit we know
that Rich's former pollster will dry is
now working with some of this group um
and can they together between now and I
think their deadline which is around the
time of the local elections in May
managed to get enough MPS on board it
seems quite difficult right now but what
is striking is the fact there is money
behind it and people with a lot of time
on their hands Katie how seriously
should we take this plot as you
mentioned there there's money behind it
there's serious people behind it but at
the same time you had Liz trust's former
Minister Simon Clark calling for the
prime minister to go just last week and
that was pushed back on there's been
very little public support especially
within the Tory party for him doing so
so how much appetite is there really how
much momentum is there to as riak so I
think right now this is a plot that is
largely taking place outside of
parliament there are more Tory MPS than
just Simon Clark who privately will say
they don't think rushi Sak's very good
they think if the polling is this bad
perhaps you should roll the dice but
there are really small number lots of
people are scarred from the fact that
they you know got rid of two leaders in
the space of two years and the polling
has really gone in the wrong direction
since but I think the reason that it is
something to note is just the fact that
there is this movement and there are uh
you know you look around things are not
looking very good for rishy sunak you
have Difficult by elction next week
you've got the local elections in May so
therefore if you're judging out on where
they will be able to ask Rishi sunak I
think most people tell you that seems
pretty far-fetched right now no one's
jumping in but then again they don't
actually have to succeed to cause Rishi
some serious problems naen you'll
recognize the uh title of Katie's cover
this week the plot it was inspired by
your book cover uh the plot H as Katie
mentions in the piece you were writing
some time ago about plot to Al Boris
Johnson do you see familiarities between
what you were writing about then and
what's happening now well I actually
write in my book The Plot that Rishi
sunak would go through exactly the same
problems that Boris Johnson had and that
they would try to remove him fairly soon
too in fact I went to both my agents and
my Publishers in December 2022 when
vishi sunak had only been prime minister
three months and said he's got a very
short time before they start moving to
get him out as well and um and yeah it's
predicted along with lots of other
things in the book so the and the reason
why I know this is because the people
who were behind putting rishy sunak into
place in the first place the people who
are behind removing Boris Johnson Annie
and Duncan Smith and Teresa may and
actually via a technical process forcing
David Cameron into position where he had
to resign those same people put Rishi
sunak in place and they do this because
they're desperate to remain in power
because they have this really unique
role at the heart of government
unidentified for over 20 years and and
most the most them people don't even
know Michael Gove everybody knows
Dominick Cummings people now know but
he's been around since 2001 douge Smith
people now know because of the plot and
he's been outed through the plot and it
was reported only a couple of weeks ago
I think that douge Smith was advising
the plot of and the reason why he's
moved from the person he put into Power
who was Rishi sunak onto Camy badok is
because they desperately need to keep
inside number 10 and inside Westminster
and they see it all disappearing in
front of their eyes now that they're 20
point basically they got it wrong by
plotting to remove Boris Johnson and
getting rid of Boris Johnson they they
got it so wrong and they expected to be
in a different place to where they are
now which is why you will see ever
increasingly desperate attempts to smear
Rishi sunak in an attempt to force mpes
to move like a herd as they did against
Boris Johnson to get their letters into
gra Brady and to remove him and you will
see constant constant praise constant
Applause
constant presentation of of K badok as
the replacement for Rishi sunak and that
will continue until they move him and
I'll just give you a date kind of like
how they will work this they they wanted
Boris Johnson out before Parliament Rose
for the summer recess in the July of
2022 and they achieved that and they
will be looking for a key Milestone with
rishy sunak they'll be looking either
for the May elections or for Easter I
can't believe they will go as far as
July but they will they will as you've
seen reported in the media
be by cut by cut by a process of
attrition constantly putting out
negative news stories about rishun until
they get to the point where they can get
him out and what we'll be driving them
on is that they will say Boris Johnson
turned it around in six months and they
think K Bok will be able to do the same
Katie in your cover you have some of the
details that the plotters are thinking
about for their timeline can you talk us
through those and also to nen's point
there about turning things around you
write in your that the Assumption um
that Rishi sunx supporters made was that
there would be time to get the polls
into a better place actually things got
worse will the plotters be thinking the
same thing that it's only going to take
a change of leader to see things improve
yes so I think in terms of the timeline
on this um I think that it's probably
seen through a few events that they can
use to destabilize RI sunak and one is
next week um when you have two
byelections um I think speaking to
summon government there is a sense that
next week could be one of the worst
weeks yet for rishy sunak which is
probably saying something given he's had
some pretty bad weeks um in the sense
you're going to have inflation figures I
think inflation will not be going the
way they want it to you're going to have
figures on growth that could show the UK
has been in a recession and then you
could top that all off on the Friday by
losing two tour seats now number 10 will
turn around and say these seats are
really hard to win one was sparked by
Chris Skidmore was a completely
unnecessary by ction given the seats
going to go any anyway at the next
election he just didn't want to stick it
out um the other Peter bone clearly was
uh it's a very difficult by elction you
think at the terms he had to uh you know
lose a whip and so forth and had his
punishment for um and then so I think
they'll be looking at the reform vote
there to try and say if reform does well
look we need to move more to the right
that this isn't working the current
strategy then I think you'll start to
have more poent enally on just the
general uh focus on boats is ry's policy
going to work and then I think building
up to the local elections when you will
start to potentially have a bit of a a
horror result in the sense the last time
the local elections in terms of these
councils were contested was a high point
of the Boris Johnson Premiership I think
in return the Tories will be trying to
focus Minds on the budget and trying to
say you more tax cuts are coming stick
with our plan and and trying to kick in
some loyalty that way um so so it builds
up to then I think even the plotters and
again they're not just one group but you
speak to different figures who want to
ask riak nearly all will concede that
they don't think you can go to nadin's
point much later than may they see the
two weeks after the May local elections
as the time one would have to act I
spoke to one who said you know if if the
MPS don't go for it by that point they
will happily retire and leave them to it
let's see if that happens but that gives
you a sense of the times and then I
think in terms of if you want to
understand the logic of those pushing
for a new leader um they would argue I
think the argument is um if you the
party is probably heading to defeat
regardless but the scale of defeat is
very important in terms of rebuilding
the party after how long you stay in
opposition and they think the don't know
voters are largely leave voters the 2019
voters and the current uh situation and
rishy sunak is not going to have that
appeal the best thing to do is get a new
leader new leader TBC um who then hits
ground running with a week of these uh
big announcements particularly those on
immigration and makes a new impression
from the public and it goes from there
now of course this is all a little bit
Fantastical in the sense are there
really you know four really good news
announcements to do that would fix the
Tory party's fortunes I think that might
be um a little bit wishful thinking but
that is I think how they has start to
think you move to a new leader who can
then make a fresh impression
particularly on leave voters where they
think that Richie cck has you know seen
his popularity fall quite a lot lot so
um Katie mentioned May the Welling BR by
elction is going to be um a seismic
moment and it will depend very much on
how what reform poll in that election I
mean I can't see them winning it but you
know benhabib who's the reform candidate
everybody knows his name and if reform
poll more than 13 14 15% I think you'll
see the um conservative party go into
what is almost a nervous breakdown point
and I think Rishi sunak if reform did
really well in that election would
really struggle to survive past that day
the one thing that both Boris Johnson
and David Cameron did do and George
Osborne did do when they were in power
was they always had an eye to what was
ukip then reform and the left and they
constantly position policies to make
sure that they had stakes in those
ground Rishi sunak has abandoned the
left by abandoning environmental
policies and others needs abandon the
right to with the winter framework
agreement and immigration and and so
he's in a very narrow place in terms of
policy ground and I think he'll find it
very difficult to survive Welling BR if
that if reform do well and you know ktie
you talked about tax cuts those tax cuts
aren't coming in any way it's not just
immigration it's immigration and tax
cuts it's actually about conservatism
and that we know the tax cuts there's
already been this kind of like um
expectation management of oh we said
there was going to be tax cuts to calm
everybody down actually there aren't
going to be tax cuts possibly because of
a demand for increasing defense spending
so there's not going to be those tax
cuts and we you know the the reanda bill
are we going to see the planes take off
and you know how many how many illegal
immigrants are we going to see being
returned or sent over to Randa that's
not going to make any huge impact is it
and the fact that you know rishy sunak
very this week has made three massive
gaps you know shaking hands with Pier
Morgan I mean what what a performance by
Pier Oran but you know for any prime
minister with any Integrity or dignity
to shake hands with ,000 back over the
lives of people who traveled across
Dangerous Waters to get here was just
completely tackless and also you know
hugging uh in Northern Ireland with
shimpan it's just it's um his and you
know today at Prime Minister's questions
when the mother of be G was sat in the
public Gallery it's just Gaff after Gaff
and the one thing I remember Boris
Johnson saying to me at the time Liz
trust went and there was that meeting
between Penny Moren to Boris Johnson and
richy sunuk and Boris Johnson about who
should take over the only person who
actually had the mandate to take over
was Boris Johnson and I think Boris said
to me at that time that he looked rishy
in the eye and they said what they've
done to me they'll do to you too and I
think it was the only point at which
runak froze and um looked that his
confidence was dented you may think
think rationally that the right policy
announcements are what will bring the
party together that won't be what gets
rid of Rishi sunak what will remove
vishaka some serious I would imagine
pieces of information that those who've
been close to him for the last seven or
eight years who actually put him into
Power will decide to use against him in
the near future Katie is number 10
worried about the plots that are uh
being whipped up to remove the Prime
Minister and naen earlier mentioned
potential Runners and writers K bad knck
being one of them uh the trade secretary
has publicly suggested that she has no
interest in replacing the Prime Minister
anytime soon that she backs rishy sunak
but what will they be thinking inside
number 10 as these details as your cover
piece um uh includes come to light so I
think the view of number 10 is they're
not nonchalant I mean they're trying not
to suggest that overly worried in the
sense oh it's an amateur hour plot look
at these people going around claiming
they're going to bring down the Prime
Minister and I think there's been an
effort to almost try and um you know
we've seen some names come out I think
there's a view of trying to find out who
the donors are it's harder to hide in
you know daylight than nighttime um but
I think there is definitely some alarm
because it's not just about a handful of
MPS um to Nadine's point it feels as
though you know there's different forces
in the background there's obviously
people who who want to throw some money
at this and so forth and it doesn't
actually take that much money if you
think about the price of a poll like the
MRP poll that the telegraph ran um by
the mysterious Alliance a couple of
£10,000 which on the grand scheme of
things I don't mean this is about doing
a 1,000 B but probably for that level of
money and for the level of disruption it
caused to the Tory party and the
dominant force in politics I mean it
doesn't take that much to start using
these figures to do things like that so
I think there is concern I don't think
there is panic um I just think there is
a sense that they may not I think the
viewers more they're unlikely to be able
to house Zak that's the view from number
10 um but they can do plenty of harm in
the process and then I think to the
point of uh success as whether it's list
side or after an election is names like
Camy Bok Penny Moran who do come up if
you had a very Swift contest you need
about over a hundred names really to get
to that point um so I think that even
those who perhaps supportive of su braan
in theory they would um probably think
that she would struggle to get the
required number
H naen last question I was looking at
some of the reviews of your book the
plot when it came out uh just before we
started to record um and I won't list
some of the things that were said
there's no need but there's a lot of
skepticism let's say and criticism of
some of the ideas you put forward in
that book mainly around this idea of a
plot and this idea of conspiracy what is
your reaction now so yeah I expected the
criticism because I was told before the
book came out what the criticism was
going to be what the plotters you know I
was told David Cameron and Michael go
are going to say that you're you know
you sold three million books you're a
great fiction writer and that you know
that I knew the attacks would come in
you know I'm a woman I'm you know a a
different kind of conservative than
people are used to and I knew those
attacks would come but what I found
absolutely fascinating is people who
attack it and now running with stories
from the book so I find it really
interesting that the same people who
attack it are picking the bits to the
stories out of it that they want to run
with and making their own stories from
it so you know it is what it is it's
sold incredibly well and um and and it's
selling consistently well every week
which is interesting because normally
you get like a big you know a big sales
and it and it tails off it's actually
selling consistently well every week and
I and I just know from the feedback that
I'm getting just not just from
journalists but from from party members
from just the public who are reading it
the feedback I get is
tends to boil down to it all makes sense
and it does all make sense and I just
want to make one final point you know
those people who who worked with Rishi
sunak to get him into Power have been
working with KY badok for an equally
long period of time because they always
have an air in a spare they never don't
have somebody in reserve so and the idea
to them that it would be Penny Mor would
be absolutely AB Boren and they will
only go when they know they can get Camy
into place and the danger of penny has
passed well perhaps we won't need the
film version of the plot if we see it
play out in real time n and Katie thank
you so much for joining me Whits are
being signed off work with long-term
sickness at a higher rate than ever
before is co the only thing to blame how
can we get people back into the
workforce our data editor Michael
Simmons and Universal Credit architect
and Duncan Smith join me on the
show Michael you write this week about
revisions to the labor force survey and
how it reveals just how large Britain's
sick note has become talk us through it
so the labor force survey is one of the
the kind of key tools that the office of
national statistics use to make
important estimates about the country's
Workforce so the employment rate
unemployment economic activity um and
things like that and last Autumn the ons
basically had to abandon publishing it
because the data was becoming more and
more unreliable because the response
rates were going low uh were down there
were certain biases in the survey that
meant statisticians didn't have um
confidence in the findings anymore and
basically this week they've released
part one of their sort of revisions to
the methodology and this revision was
all about the population under
underlying it so basically what they
found is that Britain's population and
working age population is bigger and but
it's also a lot sicker than they had
previously fought so originally we had
fought that there were a 2.6 million
British workers who were off work
because of long-term illness and that
already was a record high but what the
new estimates have found that it was
actually under counting by 200,000 so
we're now at 2.8 million which obviously
again is a record high and this is you
know obviously not what the government
wants and not what our economy needs to
kind of get going uh Ian this is
disastrous well there's a difference
between out of work and people who are
beyond the world of work which is a
debate here at the moment uh when I was
Secretary of State we put in changes not
least of which was Universal Credit and
we saw work numbers of workless
households fall to record low numbers uh
and that was about the time I left in
2016 when I resigned uh it was all going
in the right direction and we were
getting control over that there's always
been an issue about sickness benefit but
it has exploded as uh during covid what
happened during Co I think two or three
things first of all um in reaction uh to
the likelihood of people's lost jobs the
government stepped in it eased off all
of the uh criteria uh for sanctions if
somebody refuses to take a job or uh
deliberately misses an interview or
something to make sure people do what
they're supposed to do as part of their
contract when they uh become unemployed
all those strictures were eased off for
good reasons I can understand and huge
amounts of money were pumped into the
system postco what we saw was basically
uh a real explosion uh in the numbers of
people who are TR staying permanently on
sickness benefit particularly there are
two features to this which are really
important which the government could do
uh and I've been urging them to do this
the first thing is sickness benefit the
esa employment sport was introduced by
the labor party was always
faulty uh because it's got um it's meant
to have one section that allows you to
go to work but in fact everybody ignores
that and ends up getting tugged into the
top section which has no work
requirements and so it's meant to be in
Universal Credit but there's a whole
cohort of people who should be in
Universal Credit where they would
receive help and assistance from jobs
coaches to get them into work uh and
this would be really really important
but instead of which they languish no
one sees them once you go on to sickness
benefit you pretty much don't see
anybody else for a long period of time
and nobody certainly talks to you about
work that's the difference that's why we
wanted it in Universal Credit which is
been really good at reducing workless
households and so number one they have
to do that now that's going to cost them
some money but it would certainly bear
fruit and in that group that cohort that
we're talking about something like 60%
of those who now fall into the sickness
benefit category are mental health
issues and of those interestingly enough
about 60% have depression or anxiety now
these are very treatable conditions very
treatable you know you can turn people
around get them back into work work much
quicker on those two conditions through
talking therapies Etc problem again NHS
doesn't have enough people to do that uh
and therefore we need to look into the
third sector which is doing a lot of
this anyway uh to get that back but you
know we've been a bit slow getting on
top of this because that group that
cohort could be turned around quite
quickly I think should we apply the
right people to help them get through
and back into work Michael I listed
several things there that's contributing
to those who are on long-term sick covid
Furlow NHS waiting list mental health
issues do you agree broadly that those
are the categories that we're looking at
obviously they all in overlap in many
ways as well yeah and Ian's completely
right you know there's there's been a
huge covid effect here um apart from the
the mental health problems the other
sort of big category is what they call
musculoskeletal so basically bad backs
and that seems to have specifically
exploded um after covid as well um and
there needs to be some more research to
kind of understand this and it's hard to
escape the idea that maybe working from
home has something to play in that um
but also I think working from home
there's another side to it that a lot of
people who from health conditions would
previously been completely excluded from
work now can be helped back into work
where there is more flexible working so
I think that as well as saying you know
the lockdowns and the pandemic cause
huge damage to our Workforce and wider
Society there are aspect of it that we
can say maybe can become part of the
solution as well and you you mentioned
that you think a big issue is that
postco government has not got a grip on
the number of people leaving the
workforce or taking long periods of time
of of the workforce but there were
concerns and criticisms of Universal
Credit long before the pandemic hit one
of them is that it's never been properly
invested in I think one of the pro UC
arguments has been well you're not
getting all the results you want because
you haven't actually seen the proper
investment do you think think that
Universal Credit is fit for purpose do
you think it has been properly invested
in or do you think we need to look at
the system now especially postco and
consider another overhaul no let me tell
you I put that through it is the single
biggest welfare reform that we've
undertaken it's the only serious huge
digital program in any of the
governments that you see and other
governments are looking at Universal
Credit it's perfectly fit for purpose
the question really is what do you want
to use it for uh it's in infinitely
flexible if you think about covid uh
when all those people suddenly became as
it were underemployed unemployed they'
have been queuing up outside job centers
all catching covid uh they' have been in
chaos in the job centers unable to cope
with this Universal Credit took a
million people who had become unemployed
into the benefit literally within 3
weeks that's never been done before so
it's infinitely flexible it is exactly
the right benefit it's the most flexible
one that can actually approach this
problem the problem we've got is still
the sickness benefit group that you are
talking about is not wholly in Universal
Credit and it should have been so the
underinvestment problem is that they
should have put the money into putting
it in that was the whole ambition of
Universal Credit was that then job
centers job advisers can get alongside
these people that have got problems
mental health problems particularly and
start finding Pathways into work for
them that keep them out of the sickness
benefit uh end of things and we invested
money in having the right sort of
coaches for that but what you do need is
backup so what should happen is they
would go there they'd be registered
they'd be told this is their condition
they should then be entered into
depending what the condition things like
talking therapies these can all be done
even from job centers believe it or not
so there's lots that could be done
through this Universal Credit is a tool
it depends on how the government wants
to use it it's an infinitely flexible
Tool uh right now what it's doing is it
was spending huge sums of money during
Co because that was what they wanted it
to do they should now be bringing back
many of those changes which they are to
be fair to them Universal support
alongside it which isolates those who
have got real problems starts them
through process there's a second problem
with this sickness issue too which
rarely gets touched on it's about
employers UK employers are amongst the
worst in the world at dealing with uh
their employees who have problems health
problems they very rapidly let them just
go down until they fall onto statute of
sick pay and from there they then crash
into Esa and done but yet they've
invested huge sums of money in them
during the years in Germany and other
places they're much better at trying to
make sure that those people don't fall
out of work uh they work with mental
health practitioners to make sure their
hours of work are lowered to the level
they can cope with while they get
treatment and then they build them back
up again so uh we also need to make sure
that British business supports the idea
of not getting people falling into
unemployment because it's damaging for
them and the whole problem gets worse so
it's two-sided coin this one is
government's got to do more about this
and a very positive way of doing that is
to invest in bringing the sickness
benefit under UC which would be able to
help enormously and the second aspect is
business also needs to work with
government to try and find ways which
they don't just dump people out of their
businesses out of their work uh and into
uh into sickness benefit one final
change that uh would need to be done is
that we need to bring in an in work uh
kind of conditionality too which we
originally planned which is people have
done maybe 15 20 there a lot of people
there's a huge number of people that are
sitting on part-time work uh still being
subsidized by the UK by the government
uh because that part-time work doesn't
pay enough so number one perhaps we
should get employers to pay the working
the proper rate and the second thing is
that we need to make sure that when
they're ready the work coaches will work
to get them up the hours so you start
moving from 15 hours maybe to 25 then up
to 30 and so on and so forth until they
break through from the benefit system
that's the ambition of Universal Credit
it just requires us to make sure that's
how we use it and if there's a need for
that conditionality I think most people
would understand when you're ready it's
time to move and yet Michael it seems
like something is still going badly
wrong here do you think it's an issue of
incentives are the in right incentives
in place for people to be going back to
work I mean the UK has a still a pretty
high number of job vacancies it's not at
its record high postco but it's well
over
900,000 people want to be going back to
work they can but we're speaking
specifically about longterm sick workers
who are off here interestingly they're
not all over 50 they're not people who
are necessarily struggling from being in
work for a long time we've got people in
their 20s and 30s who say they are too
sick to go to work something feels very
broken here what do you think it is yeah
um well I think incentives is certainly
part of the issue but um again not to
keep going back to lot lockdown but I
think something really changed in our
sort of psyche during lockdown and you
see the same with school absences where
basically before before we experienced
lockdowns there was always you know you
you had to be most people had to be
pretty sick pretty unwell before you
wouldn't go to school before you
wouldn't go to work and I think
something has changed where we're sort
of more accepting within ourselves um
about you know staying in and locking
ourselves away um and that's something
that's going to be really complicated to
address but it's something you know we
have to do if you look at in
internationally comparisons of Workforce
recoveries we've got one of the worst
worst in the Europe worst in the
developed world so it's something that
needs to be looked at on the issue of UC
and in work this is something that you
know the government can be putting a lot
more effort into tidying up and um you
know making that system is really
working streamlined and we've you know
reported before about some problems we
think there is with in the technical
system that that handles the in work
payment part of UC um that the DWP at
the moment doesn't seem to be doing much
to look at addressing that so things
like getting UC which is you know a good
and sensible system but getting it
working as perfectly as it can can only
help you get these people back into jobs
Michael andan thanks for joining
me some predict European elections will
lead to victories for populace across
the continent someone hoping to benefit
from this is Eric samore a French TV
commentator who's Run for the presidency
in France flop two years ago but he has
a new party now positioning him self to
the right of marine Leen and focusing on
immigration in France our Deputy editor
Freddy gray interviewed him for the
magazine this week here's a clip of that
[Music]
interview
uh
Sy Duma is a
mist
for
OPP
at
VI indidual
[Music]
fr
compl
[Music]
BL
for
m
Mar
[Music]
a movement
EX
ity
his
m
in Ukraine soldiers defending their
country have not left the battlefield
for the past two years in ke a tough law
is about to be brought in that would see
conscription apply to younger recruits
this has started a public disagreement
between President zalinski and his army
generals U our writer Stana morets has
covered this for the magazine this week
she joins me now with war historian
Anthony
Beaver spit Lana you write for the
magazine this week about the Ukrainian
Army and growing internal disagreements
about conscription tell us about what's
happening between President zinsky and
his top
General first of all we have ended in
the situation when Ukraine is enter in
the third year of the fulls scale war
and we have not we don't have enough
soldiers in our army so the our army
Commander zi he offered that this year
Ukraine has to conscript up to half a
million people while zalinsky said that
Ukraine can't afforded because cons
conscripting this amount of people will
cost at least 10 billion pounds and it's
only for paying their salaries clothing
food and equipment and training Ukraine
can't use the Western aid for paying for
soldiers and also the our budget deficit
this year is at least 30 billion pounds
so he said Ukraine can't afford this
amount that's why uh right now there are
talks that the land wants to fire Z and
find a new commanderin-chief and he
hopes that the new par will give a fresh
start for Ukraine's for effort you
mentioned in your piece that in the
second world war the average age of
combat was 26 in the faulin it was 23
for a Ukrainian Soldier it's 43 I think
that's going to surprise a lot of people
a clear decision has been made so far to
conscript a slightly older generation to
keep the young people uh at home and and
working and keeping the economy afloat
but it's not about to
change yes right now um before the
minimum conscription age was uh 27 and
with the new low they going to low it to
25 and Al also all the men aged from 18
to 24 they will have to underdo uh a
military training for five
months and of course uh it is more
efficient to have younger people in the
Army and they can be trained by our
Western allies and become drone
operators or they can work in
intelligence communication that's why uh
before it was they conscripted older
people because they thought okay younger
will stay and rebild to the country
after the war ends anony as fana has
suggested this is miles apart from other
wars in the way that conscription has
taken place
what's the strategy here and how does it
compare to the
Past well it's very different as she
rightly pointed out between they say the
Second World War uh and the Faulkland
and so forth uh and in many ways I think
it was a an intelligent move at the
beginning but quite honestly the
pressure of events has actually changed
considerably and I think that zalinski
is not facing up to the facts on the
ground uh and I think the solution
General solution is is is absolutely
right and if you leave it too long uh
the crisis is actually going to get far
worse if you start throwing in basically
untrained troops at the last moment uh
you're going to face massive losses
because it's not just a question of the
training it's a question of how you
introduce these young recruits uh or
much younger recruits into the front
line and what they must do is learn from
the terrible mistakes made by the
British and the Americans in Normandy uh
where these soldiers were thrown forward
uh and unprepared and most of them had
psychological breakdowns the casualties
in their first few days uh were terrible
and the established troops the trained
troops who were the vital ones didn't
want to have anything to do with the
young ones who were arriving um they B
basically shun them which made the
situation even worse so it is terribly
important as I say uh to have mentors
who will look after them in their first
few days in contct uh in combat uh and I
think this is the real lesson that uh
basically Ukraine should learn from our
mistakes in the second world war Anthony
what do you make about that point about
spending 10 billion pounds is a lot of
money in the UK but in a country like
Ukraine I think that amounts to roughly
a quarter
of of government spending at the moment
seeing as they can't move military aid
around easily how are they going to find
the money to bring on these younger
recruits well one of the problems is
that uh for various complicated reasons
uh they cannot use foreign aid in paying
troops uh or they should be able to use
be able to equip them all right uh but
the point is I think they're trying to
do perhaps too much too quickly um
they've got to start doing it and I
think this uh standoff between zinski
and Zushi uh is is tragic at this
particular moment because uh this is
where some form of compromise has got to
be found uh but the economic one is a
very very difficult one yes it's going
to cost a lot of money um but it's
absolutely vital for Ukraine's um
survival uh the issue is that the lack
of man on the front line has already
started to take a allll on the
Battlefield and last week Russian forces
already entered a theka city in the
dunesque region that they were trying to
capture for a decade uh they also
prepared 40,000 troops to try to capture
kopans in harv region and only 20,000
Ukrainian troops will be there to defend
the city and soldiers I've been talking
to uh who who are preparing for the
fight or who are already fighting all of
them say that they need more troop they
need reinforcements they are tired they
have have been fighting for two years
and they can't understand why other men
why should be why should it be on day of
War why other men don't
join SP Lana how do you've spoken there
about how the soldiers currently feel
how will Ukrainian families feel when
the conscription numbers go up and when
their sons when the younger members of
their family are going to be sent to the
front line of course nobody wants to go
to war nobody wants to die it's the
decision that Ukraine and our government
have to make or we fight or we talk with
Russia and at the moment nobody wants to
talk with Russia and all the our opinion
PS show that ukrainians are not ready
for any negotiations because we know
what comes after that Russian occupation
and all the horrors that it brings but
at the same time uh there is a big gap
between civilians and soldiers because
civilians were hoping that the war could
be won without them because especially
in the first year of the fullscale
invasion zalanski and our government
were talking that it's going to be the
year of our Victory and it didn't happen
and a lot of PE people feel disappointed
because of that Anthony there's
increasing pressure on Ukraine from
other countries around the world to
enter into some kind of conversation
with Russia but we've heard spit Lana's
comments there if that is not considered
an option for Ukraine right now it is an
inevitable outcome isn't it that more
are going to be conscripted they're
going to have to find the money but we
are probably going to see cracks in the
current plan as it exists
now well I think that uh s in her
excellent article um points to many of
the uh problems I mean the uh the young
uh just like the former generation of
the or earlier generations of the second
World War uh are not just appalled by by
the prospect of uh military service but
this this fear of being disfigured or
maimed in battle um is far greater
actually than the fear of death um and
for example in the Second World War
soldiers in the Red Army um were
terrified of becoming what were known as
sovar I.E they'd lost all their limbs
and they were treated so badly
afterwards so it's not just a question
of the money to find and pay and equip
new troops it's also a question of the
money uh to look after the troops
especially those who've been badly
wounded and maimed and lost lost limbs
uh in the fighting and I think this is
one of the uh big problems which
obviously Ukraine is facing spit Lana
what do you make of increasing pressure
on Ukraine to come to the table with
Russia and have an have a conversation
have a
negotiation I think it is very unfair
because first just Ukraine at the
beginning of the invasion Ukraine didn't
receive enough weapons and support uh to
liberate the lands and recently was
revealed that when Russian just Russian
just St mopo for example and Zion said
okay we are going to strike mop and
we're going to liberate it quickly the
West said no you are not allowed to do
that because we don't want to provoke
Putin and the Chance was lost and when
the coun offensive started and it didn't
reach any goals it was already too late
because Russians prepared they had the
Mine Fields they have had defense lines
ready so ukrainians couldn't do anything
and right now as we couldn't achieve our
goals because we didn't have a recover
for example for our troops uh now we are
told okay we see that you can't liberate
lands then you must talk and why
ukrainians don't want to talk now is
because we are not in the Advan anous
position for negotiations we can't set
our terms you know if we had some
victories on the battlefield maybe then
we could say okay look we did this and
did this that's why uh our terms are
like this and you have to comply with
them you know but right now we can't and
if if we talk with Russia now it would
be on Russia's terms How It Ends that's
why Ukraine is not ready to do
that uh Anthony last question almost
regardless of what happen happens in
this war next zalinski is going to need
his most senior politicians and Generals
in his camp on his side and he has
talked about a major reset should we
expect to see some more shakeups in
president zelinsky's top team as there
do seem to be increasing disagreements
internally in
Ukraine well I fear that may well be the
case and I think it's uh as I was saying
tragic uh that it should be coming at
such a such a time uh this is is though
one of the problems in Warfare and
especially uh for a democracy fighting a
war um they're always going to be these
sort of tensions um but I mean you've
only got to see on the other side I mean
how many generals have been sacked by
Putin uh during the earlier part of the
War uh because they were not achieving
what he had expected or what he had
hoped um well we're starting to see
similar pressures now in Ukraine but I
would add one thing also to what Sana
was just been saying uh about the
problems of negotiations and that is how
can one trust anything that Putin says
um this is one of the problems in the
past when the West was dealing with
communist leaders either in China or in
Russia during the Cold War on the whole
they could be fairly certain that these
communist leaders would uh stand by
their assurances
this cannot be trusted anymore and this
is one of the real fundamental problems
about the future of diplomacy about
geopolitics as a whole uh if you cannot
in any way trust what they say in
negotiations and let's face it Putin
wants to have uh it would like to have a
ceasefire for a time while he is
bringing in new forces preparing and uh
uh basically redeploying his troops um
he will then try and find some excuse
just to continue the war so he can grab
more territory um all of this is makes
any question of negotiation doubly
dangerous for Ukraine I agree with
Anthony that because we had budapes
memorandum with Russia we had uh two
Minsk agreements with Russia and uh
Russia both of them didn't work Russia
attacked Ukraine and in 2014 when they
invaded Crimea and donbas we made that
ceasefire and in eight years Russia came
back but with stronger forces and the
fear right now is okay if we have a deal
with Russia and Putin has time to
prepare for the next Invasion maybe the
next time cave will fall and then it
will be over for Ukraine so while we
have this chance that we can uh protect
our lands and ensure that we bring bring
back our territories we have to use it
Anthony and spana thanks for joining
spectator
TV and finally Zoe strimple has written
for spectator life this week about the
rise of the Thomas Hardy man men who
have lovely things to say to and about
women but in practice are often the
worst when it comes to romantic
relationships she joins Me
Now Zoe thanks for joining spectator TV
you write for spectator life this week
about the rise of the Thomas Hardy guy
tell us tell us why you've named men
after Thomas Hardy and what are they
like well they certainly have nothing to
do with his writing abilities um his
literary skill and Imagination depth um
humanity and the rest of it which which
kind of has has made him one of my
all-time favorite writers and actually
poets and I I don't even like poetry but
his poetry is incredible and it's also
incredible about his late wife I mean
obviously they're both dead now but at
the time he wrote These poems about his
wife Emma and they're amazing and I
think what the the piece is really about
how on one hand you could have this this
man who seems so um almost feminist
really just the the kind of streets
ahead of his of his kind of bros uh in
the 1890s or whatever in terms of how
seriously he takes women how empathetic
he is to women on the page um but then I
think the point of the piece is to is to
sort of think about well that contrasted
pretty severely with his um daily life
and approach to the women in his actual
life which involved uh treating his wife
Emma pretty badly making driving her mad
part you know possibly always going for
younger women even in his 80s kind of
still the women in their 20s 30s and it
just the point is that today there is a
similarity in terms of them in terms of
men who are like kind of Scholars of
women in the same way um I mean less
intelligently as I say but you know they
they they seem to be kind of you know
like there's this thing horse Whisperers
they're like woman Whisperers like they
understand what women want to hear they
understand how women want to spend their
time they're Charming they seduce you
but these are the ones that often
actually end up kind of breaking your
heart treating you um very callously in
the end and leaving you completely
confused and I think the sort of
slightly Wild
parallel um is that really is that on is
this kind of women be wary of that
potential split between the man who
appears to be really like an ally or
whatever you know the word was after me
too
um and how he's actually going to treat
you he may very well end up being the
heartbreaker that Thomas Hardy was um
let's pick up on that word Ally because
in the piece you write about the wary
connection that you're making between
The Men Who call themselves feminists
and allies and the men who will break
your heart what's going on here is it a
savior kind of complex is this the idea
of them actually being desperately
wanted by the women that they're
claiming to
help yeah I think there's an interesting
psychological explanation um that at
least applies to some of them like the
Casanova type that I mentioned in the
piece which I had some experience of
when I was quite a bit younger um and I
think for them it's almost like it's a
game and I think it often does originate
in a a kind of Youth or an adolescence
where they felt they were you know not
physically impotent but impotent in
terms of you know their ability to get
girlfriends or sex or female interest so
they kind of work out how to snare women
um I don't think Thomas Hardy is
actually in that same you know I don't I
think that's not what's going on for him
I think was going on for him is just a
genuinely interesting split and
contradiction that he himself was
confused by as per that quote that I put
in the piece which is I don't know how
you know I don't know why I write like
that I don't know why I'm so good at
being kind to women on the page and so
difficult with them off the page so yeah
I think I think might be a bit different
in today's setting possibly who knows I
don't actually know the actual inner
workings of Thomas Hardy's mind and we
don't expect you to Zoe we don't expect
you to we so like your thesis I I said
suppose we should say at this point
probably not all men there are plenty of
men out there who will be genuine allies
of women but I suppose I I think some of
those people you know if if they really
do support women and they respect women
they tend to be a bit quieter about it
right they show it through their actions
rather than their words perhaps the ones
to look out for are the ones who really
want to push this idea on you and and
and vocalize all the time just how much
they are an ally of of women it's become
another tool in their dating box the the
feminist kit I suppose to dating and and
perhaps that's the problem people who
who talk about this stuff and who sing
the Praises of women but then in their
actions don't show
it I mean I I actually see that across
the board in all sorts of areas I mean I
I frankly see that with both genders
especially where for instance disdain
for capitalism uh is expressed
constantly you know the evils of
neoliberalism the evils of money
grubbing and trying to be wealthy and of
course it's it ends up being
hypocritical so I don't know I think I
do think the kind of people who feel
that they are progressive often
engage in a lot of yeah it's virtue
signaling and it it's not always
correlated with a genuine um sort of
intuitive feel for what they say they
they believe and you know some of as you
say some of the men who I know who are
the most you know who think it's the
most self-evident that that women
deserve
the full respect of human beings um of
any kind you know they they they
wouldn't even think to make a politics
out of that you know that that just is
sort of obvious to them so I think
that's that's in a way you could take
that as a warning sign I think as was
it's actually interesting to consider
that I don't think Hardy was
particularly in a politics of feminism
when he was writing this stuff you know
I think there was a politics of feminism
but I don't think it had people like him
in it um at that point
the suffrage movement and what have you
whereas now things are politicized in a
slightly different way well it sounds
like Hardy saw opportunity and he was
playing probably on the kindness of a
lot of these women um as as a shot at
his opportunity um I suppose we would
describe in modern lingo what he was
doing as love bombing to some extent and
then obviously not delivering on all of
his wordy promises um but you know this
is a pretty classic example of just
being a hypocrite isn't it
yes and I wouldn't even say he love
bummed I think he just it's just the old
story where like you want to you prefer
to trade your wife in for your typist or
you know the typist gets traded in for
someone even younger and it's
it's it's it's such an old an old Trope
um rather than
necessarily being wordy I think it was
just a sort of issue with compulsion and
kind of entitlement maybe
um and and probably you know gaslighting
to use another contemporary term you
know my my impression is that his you
know wife Emma literally was driven mad
by being assumed to be mad so you know
she was having these very strong
reactions to
his sort of so-called friendship with
the woman that he was actually in love
with so she was kind of right to be
feeling like something is not not right
here but he was kind of I think making
her feel like she she wasn't right to to
feel like that so I think that is one of
the that's one of the that's when we get
into kind of murkier more subtle terrain
of
how women are you know slightly kind of
manipulated by by these very clever
clever Men actually I had a reader get
in touch about that piece and say that
he thought maybe I was missing the point
point which was that these kinds of men
are just narcissists you know and
obviously love bombing is a classic
trait of
narcissism narcissism is really
interesting because everyone's obsessed
with it now it's become like the way to
kind of pathologize a certain kind of
man um and I you know it was interesting
that that's the way this person wanted
to to see itan has there been a sudden
kind of growth in narcissists among men
I don't
know possibly I don't know either maybe
we're just getting slightly better at
calling it out but as you say it's I
mean that's K just say that's key I
that's a really important Point actually
you know the putting the women back into
this poor old you know Emma
Hardy definitely wouldn't have had the
vocabulary that we have now to sort of
call quote unquote call out um Tom or
anyone else and and we really do so we
have a much more kind of granular grasp
of the foul play
that goes on in this space yep and on
behalf of the women who came before us
we have to call them out now as you say
it's a tail as oldest time but a very
disappointing one at that Zoe thank you
very much for joining spectator
TV and that's it for this week once
again if you enjoy spectator TV do
subscribe to our YouTube channel just
click the Subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the Bell icon to
make sure you never miss an episode
thanks again for watching and do join us
again next
week
[Music]